if you only know thaäôs from his role as
the emcee use biggest bad guy you're
missing out on a few puzzle pieces from
the Mad Titans long comics history but
don't worry we are here to bring you the
things about Thanos that didn't make it
to the MCU in the MCU vanos is motivated
in his mission of galactic genocide by
an obsession with balance it's the cause
that makes him believe that for all of
the horrors he's perpetrating he's
actually doing something Noble and good
preventing the misery he experienced on
his own home planet that came from
overpopulation and strained resources
it's a pretty flawed belief but he
believes it to the very core of his
being believe it or not that's a pretty
big departure from his comic book
counterpart who believes in nothing in
several comics including those written
by his creator jim Starlin Thanos is
frequently referred to as the ultimate
nihilist for those of you who slept
through your early morning philosophy
class or missed it in the big lebowski
nihilism is a philosophical movement
that picked up steam in the mid 19th
century in its most basic form nihilism
states that nothing really exists or
matters it can be applied to different
branches of philosophy but it most
commonly refers to existential nihilism
the belief that there's no intrinsic
meaning or significance to life or moral
nihilism the belief that one's actions
are completely devoid of ethical value
in math you doing something like say
interplanetary mass murder is neither
good nor evil it simply is with no more
moral weight than eating a peanutbutter
sandwich or petting a dog that's what
makes the Pharos of the comics such a
compelling and frightening villain
especially when he's pitted against
characters who almost universally
represent the idea that one's abilities
and actions do have meaning and
consequence or to put it another way
they have great power and because of it
great responsibility for Thanos that
responsibility just doesn't exist he's
not fighting the heroes because he hates
them he's fighting them because there's
no reason not to he's not trying to
complete the Infinity Gauntlet because
he wants to control the universe
but because attaining absolute control
over reality is the only way to
literally do anything that matters at
all for all of our cheerful talk of
nihilism and the futility of existence
it's worth noting that the Thanos of the
comics page isn't entirely without
motivation it's not a dedication to
balance
or a twisted attempt to correct the
suffering of his past
it's that Thanos just straight-up once
to get his bone on in a very literal
sense in the comics Thanos is in love
with death not the concept per se but
the lady shaped embodiment thereof see
in the Marvel Universe the most
fundamental concepts stuff like order
chaos
love hate eternity and so on exist both
as abstract ideas and as beings with
physical forms death is one of those and
apparently her physical form is very
appealing to Thanos despite the fact
that she's usually represented as an
upsettingly shapely skeleton and only
occasionally has things that most of us
would find attractive like skin or
eyeballs after seeing death as a thirsty
teen Thanos decides that the best way to
impress her would be to kill as many
living beings as possible giving
countless souls to her in the nihilistic
cosmic equivalent of subscribing to her
only fans unsurprisingly
this didn't really work out that well
because you know she's deaf and giving
her dead people is sort of like giving a
heart-shaped box of chocolates to Willy
Wonka despite taking a keen interest in
Thanos and his exploits death remains
distant and she's actually way more into
Deadpool with whom she shacks up during
his brief periods of being dead while
his healing factor stitches his body
back together no joke the Thanos
Deadpool death love triangle is 100%
canon if you're in the roughly 100% of
people living on the planet Earth who
saw Avengers infinity war you know the
mad Titans ultimate goal after
assembling all six of the Infinity
stones is to wipe out half of the
sentient life in the universe with a
single snap of his fingers
[Music]
this actually is something that was
brought to scream directly from the
comics what didn't make it was the
context on the screen the end of
billions and billions of lives across
the galaxy is what Thanos has been
working towards for 10 years it's the
culmination of his plan the end that has
justified all his horrendous means but
in the comics it's just his opening act
halfway through 1991's the Infinity
Gauntlet number one not even the climax
of the first issue
Thanos attempts to prove both his
incredible power and his devotion to
death by killing half the universe with
a snap of his fingers it's meant to be a
chilling depiction of how powerful he's
become that such a massive act can
happen just like that
of course it also has the benefit of
keeping the cast at a manageable size
and getting rid of problematic
characters like daredevil who wouldn't
fit with the cosmic action and the
Fantastic Four who have too much
experience with cosmic battles it's
definitely one of the most memorable
moments of the story although removing
it from that context gives the movies
infinity saga one of its weirdest little
quirks in the comics the snapping of
fingers is meant to illustrate how
effortless it is in the movie it's
apparently something you have to do in
order to use the stones something that
has the biggest ratio of inherent
silliness to serious presentation in the
entire franchise forget about the head
Thor should have aimed for the thumbs
stop us if you've heard this one there's
a comic book about this kid who's a
child of a prominent family but he feels
like an outcast due to the fears and
doubts he has about himself one day he
falls into a cave and while the
experience is frightening for him
it also comes to define him forcing him
to confront and embrace the darker side
of himself in shaping his future you
know about that right of course you do
what fetch
that's right in me
this time my enemies shared my dreads
everyone knows about the secret origin
of vanos wait who are you thinking of
okay yes the broad strokes of the origin
have a few notable similarities to a
certain Dark Knight published by
Marvel's distinguished competition but
the details are very different see when
he was a kid back on Titan Thanos was
quiet and reserved and thought of
himself as an outcast until he finally
made a few friends at immortal space God
elementary school in an effort to
impress his new pals little Thanos led
them into a cave in search of gems the
same activity that would come to define
his adult life unfortunately it wasn't a
great field trip the floor gave way
beneath him and he was separated from
his buddies buried under rubble he was
down there for three days and despite
the fact that he was surrounded by
lizard creatures that he could have
easily eaten for sustenance he chose to
remain hungry rather than take another
life as he tried to dig his way out
before he finally lost his strength then
came the ironic twist when he did
finally dig himself out he found that
those same creatures that he wouldn't
eat even to save his own life had no
such compunction z' of their own and
they'd eaten his friends leaving only a
pair of skeletons little c was horrified
and after he escaped the cave he later
returned to exact some lethal revenge
giving him his first taste of what it
was like to take a life the movies don't
really get into palaces history
preferring to show him as more of a
force of nature than someone who's
suffered childhood trauma but unless
Marvel Studios wanted Bruce Wayne's
lawyers to come knocking they probably
would have left this one out anyway most
of thanassis twisty backstory is left on
the page purely for concerns of space
and streamlining the chunk of the Mad
Titans origin story that we see in
cosmic Ghost Rider however is unlikely
to ever make it to the page by virtue of
being weird even by Marvel standards see
if you can keep up with this one cosmic
Ghost Rider was well a cosmic Lee
powered version of Ghost Rider from an
alternate future who rode across space
on a flaming motorcycle as a herald of
that futures version of Thanos who
succeeded in eliminating every single
person on earth despite speaking with a
goofy insane patter that made it seem
like he might have been Deadpool
underneath his demonically flaming skull
it turned out
CGR was actually frank castle better
known as the punisher after being killed
in Earth's fight with Thanos and sent to
hell for you know all the murders Frank
made a deal with the devil to punish the
wicked only to return to a barren planet
that had no life wicked or otherwise for
him to punish the decades of isolation
drove him to madness and then he became
The Herald of Galactus obtaining the
power cosmic in an attempt to get
revenge on Thanos but he then turned on
Galactus when Thanos offered to take him
to the larger Marvel multiverse with
endless evil people to punish shoot
that's his origin story and since we
haven't even gotten to the part that
effects the primary Thanos yet you
likely already know why this one won't
make it onto film anytime soon after
finding his way to the core marvel
universe the cosmic castle decided to
rectify the mistakes of his past and
after travelling back in time he
abducted Thanos from Titan as a baby in
hopes of raising him to be somewhat less
Jenna Seidel surprise surprise being
parented by a serial killer possessed as
a vengeance demon didn't create the
pacifist Thanos that CGR hoped it would
in fact it made him even worse the
writer tried to undo his error and
return baby Thanos to his proper point
in the timestream but he was informed by
Death herself that his actions had
imprinted the tendency towards violence
on little T that he would display as an
adult good job Frank
Loki might have been the driving force
behind the Avengers formation and
Ultron's actions were so devastating
that it tore the team apart but in the
big picture their small time Thanos is
the biggest bad guy in the entire MCU
and not just because of his evil schemes
he's a physical powerhouse able to land
a truly brutal beatdown to the Hulk
survive being axed by Thor and go
toe-to-toe with Captain Marvel and her
nearly infinite cosmic power he needs to
be that powerful to justify not just a
decade and lurking in the background as
a looming threat but two movies that
feature him as the primary villain who
needs every single hero in the universe
to rally together to defeat him
I am inevitable
so naturally the filmmakers left out the
time that he got trounced by during
green the unbeatable Squirrel Girl if
you're not familiar with her
the unbeatable isn't an exaggeration
invested with the powers of both girl
and squirrel including the proportionate
strength and agility of the common
ground squirrel and exceptionally sharp
front teeth scroll girl beat dr. doom in
her first appearance and has remained
undefeated in the years since it's
become something of a running gag and a
fundamental truth of the Marvel Universe
that you just can't feed her no matter
how much you might theoretically
outclass squirrel powers she wants to
hand at Bannos a first round knockout on
Christmas Eve and the watcher showed up
to confirm that this one was the real
deal kind of weird that they didn't call
her for backup during endgame huh check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
[Music]